[Musique]
dans l'actualité de ce 28 mars dans les
yvelines la solidarité continue de
s'organiser dans le département entre
accueil des réfugiés vote de subventions
et départ de convois nous faisons le
point les chasseurs interpellés lors du
salon de la chasse à mantes-la-jolie ce
week end des militants du parti
animalistes sont venus dénoncer leurs
pratiques quelques jours après une vidéo
polémique montrant un jeune cerf achevée
en pleine ville à gros rouvre à montigny
le bretonneux l'oeuvre de l'architecte
marta pan sera prochainement rénové un
chantier d'envergure qui traversera une
grande partie de la ville
le projet a été dévoilé
[Musique]
la valse des palettes va durer jusqu'au
4 avril dans cet ancien entrepôt de la
poste le département des yvelines stocke
tous les dons reçus des 110 villes
participant à la collecte si 150
palettes et ça fera peu près 20 camions
20 semi remorque qui vont partir pour
l'ukraine voilà pour aider le peuple
ukrainien est vraiment un énorme enfin
une énorme solidarité viennoise enfin
ces deux petits villages de 210
habitants à des grosses communes comme
versailles où on finit le 4 avril les
quelques communes qui avaient pas été
collectés après ben on verra dans la
durée s'il faut s'il faut continuer une
collecte réalisée avec l'association
act-up ong françaises trois camions vont
partir chaque jour avec des produits
d'hygiène de couchage aide alimentaire
des dons qui partait de l'accueil pour
ceux qui arrivent le département lui
même a accueilli 8 ukrainien alors en
vacances en france du côté de poissy
cinq sportifs et leurs entraîneurs sont
reçus par le club de football la
préfecture des yvelines travail avec les
collectivités locales et permet aux
déplacés de demander la protection
temporaire une autorisation provisoire
de séjour d'une durée de six mois allez
le loisir de 51 ans est l'une des
réfugiés sont hébergés depuis deux
semaines plus de 650 places sont
référencés dans le département
[Musique]
après le collège court bell il ya une
semaine ce sont les enseignants de youri
gagarine qui se mobilisaient ce lundi
matin à trappes environ 30 de la
quarantaine de professeurs n'ont pas
assuré leurs cours une grève contre la
dotation horaire globale attribuée à
leur établissement situé en zone
d'éducation prioritaire en force est
calculée par l'académie cette dotation
permet de déterminer le nombre de
classes en fonction du nombre d'élèves
selon ces enseignants qui ont reçu le
soutien du maire de trappes il faudrait
deux classes supplémentaires à la
rentrée prochaine le calcul qui a été
fait par l'inspection académique pour
nous ne correspond pas à la réalité du
collège actuel et à la réalité de la
rentrée prochaine on se retrouve avec
des classes un petit peu plus chargé et
à chaque fois qui dit des classes un
petit peu plus chargé 10 des professeurs
moins disponibles pour chaque élève on a
ici une segpa on a des enfants aussi
qu'ils ont du mal avec le français
parfois qui ont du retard scolaire et
pour les accompagner convenablement leur
permettre de réussir et ne pas les
condamner à l'échec dès le plus jeune
âge eh bien il faut mettre le paquet de
son côté l'académie de versailles joint
par notre rédaction assure poursuivre
son engagement pour une répartition
équitable des moyens entre
établissements au collège gagarine c'est
la baisse constante des élèves qui
justifie la dotation pour la rentrée
prochaine l'établissement de plus de 400
élèves auraient perdu près de 80 jeunes
en quatre ans pour la rentrée 2022 une
baisse de 37 élèves est prévue sur le
secteur de recrutement du collège la
dotation horaire globale traduit donc
l'évolution des effectifs au sein du
collège avec 37 élèves en moins
l'établissement comptera une classe en
moins les moyens mis à disposition du
collège permettront de maintenir en
moyenne 25 élèves par classe 25 dans un
collège comme le nôtre c'est déjà trop
donc la base qui est choisie par le
rectorat de dire à 25 vous serez bien
c'est une base qui est faussé autre
grief pour ces professeurs la mauvaise
répartition des élèves dans les trois
collèges de la ville youri gagarine et
gustave courbet perdre des effectifs
alors que celui du village est surchargé
ils craignent à terme comme conséquence
des suppressions de postes et demandent
une refonte de la carte scolaire au
conseil départemental des yvelines
compétent en la matière sans réponse
pour le moment la collectivité n'a pas
souhaité s'exprimer sur le sujet à notre
micro
les professeurs mobilisés seront reçus
ce lundi soir par l'inspection
académique
il n'exclut pas d'autres actions dans
les prochains jours
[Musique]
l'ile-de-france premier désert médical
de france au delà de la surprise la
réalité des chiffres 62% de la
population régionale est touché par une
offre de soins insuffisante ou par les
difficultés dans l'accès aux soins
contre 38% en 2018 dans le détail en
disant l'union régionale des
professionnels de santé estime que 3742
postes de médecins libéraux n'ont pas
été renouvelés les professions de
dermatologues de gynécologues ou encore
de rhumatologues sont également
concernés on notera que le département
des mines présentent une situation
particulièrement inquiétante avec 943
généralistes recensés pour 1,4 million
d'habitants
[Musique]
ils n'étaient pas nombreux mais ils ont
donné de la voix les militants du parti
animalistes se sont rendus ce week end
aux abords du salon international de la
chasse dans les yvelines quelques jours
après la diffusion sur les réseaux de la
mise à mort d'un cerf aux abois à les
pieux en pleine rue à cros rouvre les
manifestants voulaient rappeler l'agonie
et la souffrance entraîné par une
pratique qu'ils jugent barbare c'est une
logique complètement incompréhensible
voilà pour ça je veux qu'on arrête de
tuer des animaux pour un plaisir qu'elle
nous dise pas que c'est pour la
nourriture c'est complètement fou comme
le disait lamartine on n'a pas de coeur
on a pas on a pas un pour les humains et
un pour les animaux on en a on en a pas
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui d'une manière
générale d'ailleurs je trouve que
la société pousse les gens en fait à ne
plus avoir d'émotions de leur côté les
chasseurs souhaitait faire preuve de
pédagogie pour expliquer leurs pratiques
c'est une pratique qui doit continuer
qui doit être raisonnée mais qui doit
continuer c'est une tradition ancestrale
qu'il faut préserver cette mobilisation
intervenait à moins de deux semaines de
l'élection présidentielle et si le parti
animalistes n'a pas réussi à recueillir
le nombre nécessaire de parrainage pour
y participer il annonce d'ores et déjà
être en mesure de présenter quelques 400
candidats lors des législatives
[Musique]
l'oeuvre n'a été achevée qu'en 1994 mais
elle accuse déjà le poids des années la
perspective de marta pan qui invite les
promeneurs à déambuler du centre urbain
de saint quentin en yvelines au parc des
sources de la bièvre présente
aujourd'hui un bien triste visage après
plus d'un an d'études le projet de
restauration pourrait se concrétiser
dans les prochains mois l'annoncé
officielle vient d'avoir lieu sur le
site en fin de semaine dernière
aujourd'hui il faut à la fois restaurée
réparer et concevoir des ouvrages qui
sont à l'échelle et pérenne et durable
le problème récurrent c'est le problème
de l'eau qui à la fois sa force puisque
c'est une force une barre dont une
oeuvre construite au fil de l'eau et
l'eau et les eaux si le défaut capital
de cette oeuvre puisqu'elle a été mal
gérée on a presque trop d'eau une
mauvaise circulation une mauvaise mise
en oeuvre de tout le système de
fontainerie l'eau élément principal de
cette réalisation mais plus globalement
de l'oeuvre de l'artiste d'origine
hongroise à travers le monde s'expose
ses réalisations monumentales des états
unis au japon en passant par l'arabie
saoudite
mais ici le gigantisme de l'oeuvre est
aussi son talon d'achille qu'on a créé
des ouvrages des structures et c est un
canal à l'échelle d'une métropole et
d'une capitale là où nous sommes sûrs
capitale régionale simplement coût
probable des travaux de restauration 3
millions d'euros le label patrimoine
d'intérêt régional décerné par
l'ile-de-france devrait permettre de
faciliter l'obtention des subventions on
a vraiment lancé depuis 2016 une vaste
un vaste programme
culturel de façon à pouvoir valoriser
tout ce patrimoine qui ont j'allais dire
petit patrimoine qui n'est pas si petit
que ça mais qui n'est pas financé au
titre des monuments historiques et donc
les malheureusement se dégrade aussi et
donc a besoin de financement dont 12,7
création de ce label de quoi célébrer ce
moment avec quelques notes de musique et
quelques mouvements de danse
[Musique]
il a ouvert ses portes aux élèves il ya
deux semaines le forum des arts charles
aznavour à montigny le bretonneux a
revêtu son plus bel écrin le samedi 26
mars pour les inimités les habitants
pouvaient découvrir ce bâtiment de 3500
m² qui rassemble le conservatoire de
musique l'école de théâtre et deux
associations de danse j'ai cru
comprendre que les élèves quand ils sont
rentrés pour la première fois été
émerveillé par ce que le bâtiment est
magnifique et parce qu'ils ont aussi des
conditions de pratique maintenant qu'ils
sont absolument exceptionnel s'approprie
la salle avec plaisir les locaux tout
est beau donc ça fait plaisir dans des
vrais locaux ont été éblouis par les
salles par leurs vêtements les miroirs
les bars on a l'impression d'être une
compagnie professionnelle et je pense
qu'on danse bien mieux depuis qu'on est
là un maudit thorium 250 places des
studios d'enregistrement et de
répétition des studios de théâtre et de
danse le lieu offre un équipement de
meilleure qualité et adaptées aux
différentes pratiques quand on joue j'ai
trouvé que l' orchestre
était un peu décuplée je trouvais qu'on
entendait plus les instruments on on
avait une meilleure appréciation de ce
qu'ont joué et
c'est satisfaisant en fait les salles
sont beaucoup plus grandes il ya un noir
complet et les projecteurs sont bien
aussi non on a eu besoin de prendre nos
marques c'est vrai que ça change
beaucoup en terme d' espaces de
revêtement au sol des barons on retrouve
des barres mobiles qu'on n'avait pas
avant un lieu qui permettra aux trois
disciplines de s'exprimer
individuellement mais aussi
conjointement c'est agréable en fait
quand on arrive à nos cours on entend
alors qu'istres qui joue on voit donc
c'est sympa d'être mêlés comme ça à
d'autres disciplines c'est une chance
incroyable d'avoir un lieu où nous nous
retrouvons tous c'est une ruche il y à
des musiciens des danseurs des théâtreux
c1 donne envie de faire plein de projets
interdisciplinaires
donc c'est une nourriture merveilleuse
au total plus de 1800 élèves sont
inscrits dans les différentes écoles un
conservatoire des arts plastiques
devrait également s'installer sur place
par la suite
[Musique]